I was on 60 mg of morphine twice a day
plus oxycontin in between plus Arthur
tech for inflammation and then they
wanted to put me on antidepressants
because I was depressed you don't have a
life you're just your eyes are dead
many advocates of health care reform
think that Canada's single-payer system
is far superior to the United States's
mixed system this is the story of Cheryl
Baxter who badly needed a hip
replacement operation I got a phone call
at my office on Tuesday saying the
doctor wanted to see me when I thought
oh boy I'm going to have the surgery I
got a date but when I got there she said
the doctor and read there no longer is
going to do your surgery and so then I
had to go back on the hip and knee
replacement list we spent over three
years that I've waited when you go see a
doctor
they don't even look at your face
anymore they just look in their computer
screen all you are is a name and a
number we feel that our government has
led us down the issue in Canada is a
lack of access to health care services
and a lack of medical resources we don't
have as many physicians as other
countries do we don't have as many MRIs
and CTS we don't have the physical
capital in place in spite of spending
more than just about every other
developed nation on our universal access
healthcare system people always ask us
well how come he had to go over to the
states to have your surgery and said
because I couldn't get it done here I
have no idea how long that it would have
been if my daughter didn't go online and
she found timely medical and within two
weeks we were flying to Oklahoma I had
the surgery and back again timely
medical takes patients who are Canadian
waiting list to us facilities where they
pay for operations with their own money
I don't think our operation could
operate in candidate legally we got
plenty of Canadians coming to Oklahoma
City that are paying us to get their
surgery done because
it's illegal for them to do it up here
dr. Smith didn't perform Baxter's
operation but he runs a facility that's
very similar to the one that did his
surgery center of Oklahoma suggest an
alternative way to deliver healthcare
Smith Center is different than both the
Canadian system and the u.s. is
third-party payer health insurance
system we're big fans of the free market
and believe in competition and love it
and think that it raises quality and
lowers prices in medicine just like it
does in any other industry our prices
have been lower than anyone else in the
city since the day we opened we have no
bureaucracy I'm in the operating room
with with patients and with the staff if
they're if there are equipment issues
I'm aware of them immediately and we
resolve those there aren't any
committees that things go through they
just things just get handled and
everybody was so pleasant and just
treated me like a queen
we don't have waiting times where if we
say the surgery's at 8 it's at 8 I don't
I don't think most people think that
market forces or the free market are
applicable to healthcare we recently
just put our prices on the Internet so
if you if you go to our website it
clearly states that if you have your
knee operated on here's an amount the
hip was 18 thousand I put my prices
online and if one of my competitors puts
their prices online and they match me or
they're lower I'm going to respond in
the beneficiary of that is the person
that's paying for the care the function
of profit is to create efficiency is to
give an individual entrepreneur an
incentive to find a group of individuals
we're not being served well and to serve
them well at a reasonable cost that they
appreciate and so to create a voluntary
transaction between two individuals such
that they're both better off
that's the motivating factor of profit
they are scruciating pain
that I had is gone I can go to work and
I can do my housework I can put my own
socks on there are many different ways
to approach healthcare policy and the
lesson is very clear the more you rely
on market mechanisms like cost-sharing
and private competition the better the
system will be people tell me oh you
look so good no you're you've got that
sparkle back in your eyes it's terrific
it's I got my life back
[Music]